the owners of this store couldn't
believe their eyes when they check their
security footage in the morning this man
walked right through their glass doors
without slowing down or breaking them as
if he were a ghost then moments later
she did it again
and acted like it's completely normal
how could this be possible what would
you do with this power and what
scientific theory says that we could all
be capable of doing this
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you could walk through walls
even though this specific video is
shrouded in mystery and is most likely
the product of visual effects it doesn't
mean that walking through walls is
impossible if everyone were able to
figure it out then our world would
become a much different place you could
take a lot of shortcuts to work you
could walk in and out of bank vaults as
you pleased or you could just feel
stressed at home waiting for a friend
neighbor or a murderer to walk through
your walls whenever they want but before
we get too carried away with the
possibilities of walking through walls
let's figure out how we could do it
scientifically speaking at first glance
it seems that it should be pretty easy
to walk through walls
after all the walls and our bodies and
everything else around us are made up of
atoms atoms are mostly empty space if
you look at the typical diagram of an
atom it kind of looks like our solar
system there are a bunch of electrons
orbiting the nucleus through empty space
just like the planets orbit around our
Sun you'd think that it should be easy
to pass our atoms through all that empty
space right well it's not that simple
in reality the electrons surround the
nucleus less like the planets in our
solar system and more like the blades of
a fan when the fan is turned off it
appears that there's a lot of space
between the blades but when you turn it
on and the blades are moving it looks
like they're everywhere at the same time
if you try and poke your finger through
those moving blades you'll quickly learn
the concept of the Pauli exclusion
principle which states that two
electrons cannot exist in the same place
at the same time essentially this
principle is why classic physics says
you can't walk through walls but luckily
there's a whole other branch of physics
that's a little more open-minded it's
name is log W physics according to
quantum physics it's incredibly
difficult for scientists to pinpoint the
precise location of an electron so
instead they map out the probabilities
of where it could be viewing an electron
like this means that if you throw one at
a barrier like a wall there's always a
tiny probability that it will end up on
the other side this theory is called
quantum tunneling it's pretty
complicated I think explaining it
anymore would probably just lead to more
confusion and it would just take more
time before we could start walking
through walls
the bottom line is that quantum
tunneling could theoretically allow all
the particles in our bodies to pass
through barriers and before we know it
everyone could be walking through walls
sure there would be a lot of people
using this ability with bad intentions
they could use it to rob stores banks
and houses with relative ease they could
sneak into locker rooms or get easy
access to attack other people but there
could be a lot of benefits police could
solve hostage situations more easily by
just entering a location from anywhere
they want and surprising the criminal by
having officers bombard them through the
walls archeologists could walk straight
into a pyramid and check out the inside
without disturbing it search and rescue
parties might be able to save more
people as they could easily search
through the rubble for anyone still
breathing and people could reach a whole
new level of intimacy by literally
merging with each other hmm
maybe we should leave these two alone
but in all honesty the odds of one
person achieving this let alone many
would be astronomical you would need
every single particle in your body to
tunnel at the same time and the odds of
one particle doing this are extremely
low you'd probably have a better chance
of figuring out how to make yourself
invisible but that's a story for another
[Music]